maxime a repris cette ancienne ferme en
2021 il élève 55 vaches Limousin et
cultive 50 hectares de céréales pour les
nourrir entre le foncier le cheptel et
le matériel le jeune trentenire a
investi 380000 € 3 ans plus tard il
n'arrive toujours pas à se dégager de
salaire faut installer des jeunes c'est
vrai mais on nous dit pas un peu le
calvaire qui qui qui peut l'être parfois
derrière que ce soit point vue de de
l'administratif ou de la réglementation
et et le salaire en fait partie je
m'attendais à à pas être forcément très
bien rémunéré au départ ça je m'y
attendais on m'avait un petit peu
prévenu mais de là à me sortir 0 € non
ça c'était ça c'était pas c'était pas du
tout prévu depuis le 1er janvier son
frère Cadé Clément s'associe avec lui à
27 ans c'était lui aussi son rêve de
vivre décemment d'un métier passion nous
les heures en soi on enfin on s'en fiche
quoi nous notre travail c'est c'est une
passion enfin tous les matins on se lève
on va pas au travail avec la boule au
ventre quoi nous on se lève tous les
matins c'est pour aller voir nos vaches
tout ça et après ensuite c'est vrai que
quand on voit à la fin du mois que ben
on peut pas se tirer de salaire c'est un
gros souci quoi c'est là la boule au
ventre voilà c'est ça la boule au ventre
elle peut commencer le matin avec
l'arrivée des
factures c'est une partie des phito 1200
€
et et bah oui il y a le camion d'engrais
aussi pratiquement 18000 € là les
produits phytosanitaires l'autre sujet
chez ces agriculteurs conventionnels qui
se sentent montrer du doigt alors que
les pratiques ont beaucoup évolué on
aurait beau mettre de l'eau dans le
pulvérisateur et aller dans un champ la
personne sans savoir ce qu'il y a dedans
va vous traiter de pollueur parce que il
voient le pulvérisateur mais il reste
passionné notamment de la génétique
voilà les jeunes reproducteur qu'on veut
essayer de valoriser à la vente donc en
jeune mal reproducteur du coup audacieux
ils viennent d'investir à nouveau plus
de 450000 € dans l'exploitation voisine
s'agrandir la seule solution aujourd'hui
pour tenter de survivre sur une surface
comme celle-ci à l'époque on faisait
vivre entre deux à trois familles
aujourd'hui une seule personne n'arrive
pas à se dégager un revenu
euh parce que soi-disant on en a pas
assez grand où on ù bah mais c'est qu'en
fait c'est tout ce qu'on paye à côté en
doublant le troupeau et la surface
cultivée Maxime et Clément l'espoir d'un
avenir meilleur à la hauteur de leur
rêve
d'enfant